so many stories about your dad would
find their way into like stories about
Frank for sure they line up they line up
really close to each other and hockey
hockey was martyr's Dad yeah oh yeah he
was in the yellow jackets gang right uh
he was the fastest thing on two feet
that's why everyone called him hockey my
dad's actual group name is called Vito
and the salutations
when she got kicked out of he got booted
out of videos they didn't think he had
the stuff where's your dad eating now my
dad uh was really thrilled by this beef
stew that he got at the flea market and
he was digging into it and had a couple
cans of it and my mom saw how much he
enjoyed it so she opened one up to have
for dinner and until she turned around
and saw that it was dog food
or like to buy anything at the flea
market and this is how a story starts
he's like
I am